hello
my name is shantam and welcome to my
talk on rapidly emulating professional
visualizations from the new york times
in python using altair
in this brief talk you will learn how
you can go from data to an effective and
interactive graphic that appeared in the
new york times
and subsequently the economist the focus
of this talk is altea
so what is altair altair is a
declarative statistical visualization
library
based on vega light and the grammar of
graphics paradigm
let's understand what vegalite grammar
graphics and declarative mean
vega lite is a high level grammar of
interactive graphics
in vegalite you make your charts by
writing them as a json syntax
vegalite then compiles that json into
the visualizations that you see
for example this json produces this
scatter plot
alter is basically a python api to
create
these valid json specifications using a
declarative approach
grammar of graphics is a very powerful
paradigm that allows you to construct
any visualization from a combination of
a few fundamental building blocks just
like lego
the fundamental building blocks are data
transformation
marks encoding scale guides
declarative visualization is the
opposite of imperative visualization
a good example of imperative
visualization package is
matplotlib now imperative cares about
how why declarative case about what
thus in declarative visualization you
declare the logic
of what end result you want to see
rather than
writing the detailed control flow steps
the key takeaway here is that
just like ggplot2 is to r so is altered
to python
both are declarative and based on
grammar of graphics
because of this declarative approach
implemented via a concise grammar
you can create a massive range of simple
to complex visualizations
and do very quick explorations and
navigation of multi-faceted datasets
let's see how this declarative approach
is quick
easy and into it in altair basic
visualizations use the following pattern
you import altair salt and then call
alt.chart
dot markedline dot encode dot properties
dot interactive maybe dot project and
some configurations
so your chart is basically a continuous
chain of method calls or building blocks
remember grammar you start with the data
and pass it
to the first building block which is the
chart class then you think about what
kind of
marks would best represent your data
points
mark area maybe mark bar mark point
mark line the choice of mark determines
the type of chart you are going to see
so there are no templates or categories
of plots but
a grammatical specification of what you
want to see of what you want to see on
the screen
next we have to figure out what visual
encodings is most effective for my data
so you specify how to map the columns of
the data frame
to the visual properties of the chart
like x-axis y-axis
color these are also called as encoding
channels
some of the encoding channels supported
by altair are x-axis y-axis
latitude longitude encodings like
facet row and column help us in creating
subpods finally you specify chart-wide
properties or configurations and
interactivity
the api construction is such that all
the aesthetics that are not specific to
the data
but to the general looks of the marg go
in mark methods like mark line
the mappings from data to properties of
chart always go
in the encode and finally the properties
that affect the chart as a whole
and are independent of mark properties
or data like height
width or in the end in properties
to get the hang of it before the actual
plot
let's see this interact declarative api
in action
on a weather data set this data set
contains weather from 2012 to 2015 for
seattle and new york
the columns are location date
precipitation
temperature maximum temperature minimum
wind and weather type
now let's explore how temperature varies
throughout the years
we specify the date data in the chart
class
let's choose mark as point then in
encoding
we specify x-axis
to date y-axis to temperature maximum
and here is interesting part to make a
subplot
so that we get two charts for the two
cities
we just map column or facet
to location and alter takes care of the
rest
because we chose mark as point we get a
faceted
scatter plot now we may want to show
locations with different colors how do
we do that
we just map color encoding to
location and we get two separate colors
for seattle and new york
if we want to find the distribution of
temperature maximum for both the cities
the way we arrive at that histogram is
that x axis maps to temperature
and on y axis we aggregate count of
temperature
finally we use mark bar alter allows us
to use aggregates like mean median
mode sum etc we can also easily make
compound charts using
plus or an and operators let's say you
want to see how precipitation varies
with wind and you want a linear
regression chart adjacent the scatter
plot
you make the chart separately scatter
plot is easy we make the regression
and then we use the r operator to get
them side by side
but wouldn't it be cool if we can plot
the regression line on top of the
scatter plot
you can absolutely do that while
layering
you do that using the plus operator
now let's visualize the new york times
go with data set
the data from new york times github
repository has five columns
date county state cases deaths and fips
fifth is just a unique numerical
identifier for counties
so on a given date we get cases and
deaths at a county level for each state
let's make maps the main thing you need
to know is that your x and y
axes get replaced by latitude and
longitude and that
there is a geometrical for maps you need
a special file called
shape file and you read it just like a
pandas data frame but using a package
called geopandas
the only difference between a data frame
and a jio data frame is that
jio data frames contain a mandatory
geometric column
that basically has the map geometry
information so we download and load the
county
shape file from u.s census you just
calculate the
longitude and the latitude of the
centroids of the counties
because your circles or spikes
will need to be at that position to
represent statistics about that region
so the final data frame looks like this
all the columns we need
plus the geometry card when we plot it
without any encoding we get this
this does not look like the map of usa
but it actually is
the maps we are familiar with is a
projected map so we project our map to
albert's usa projection
by specifying the projection in the end
much better
let's plot the cases per capita on this
map
to do that we just take the population
data from u.s census
today's cases across the u.s divide them
and then merge with the jio data frame
then we just say color it by
aces per capita now this chart by new
york times is not a simple chart
we will make this chart by layering
circle marks on top of the geosafe plot
the base map is the first map we saw
with no encoding
on top of that we layer a circle chart
where circles are centered on the
latitude and longitude of the centroids
of the counties
that we had calculated before and their
size encoding
is maps to the cases and then we use the
plus operator
and by the way getting tool tips is as
easy
as mapping a list of columns to the
tooltip encoding as you can see here
well this does not quite look like the
visualization by new york times
however we can make it look like that by
changing the scale
what we are seeing is actually accurate
but the issue is that the range of
values of cases is very large
and by default this is what alder comes
up with
if we contract our domain alter
increases the relative size of circles
if you experiment you will find that a
domain of zero to ten thousand works
really well
and since we want this for size that is
where we specify scale equals to alt dot
scale domain zero to ten thousand
and we get this now this is much better
remember we used to specify encodings as
strings in actuality every encoding is a
class
and that allows you to tweak it as you
like
now what we see in this new york times
chart is a custom shape
in altair the cool part of mark point is
that it allows you
to create your own custom shapes like a
star or a balloon and in our case a
triangle without a base
using an svg path this svg path string
represents this triangular spike
this -5 in the middle is what controls
the height of the spike
so when we run this code by specifying
this svg string for the shape property
of marked point
we get this but wait we are seeing
changes in
area not height the reason it does that
is because we perceive changes in area
better
but we only want the heights of the
spikes to change so how do we solve this
unfortunately we don't have a scale y
encoding if we had that we would have
just specified that encoding for cases
what if we make a new column made up of
those svg path strings with changing
heights for each data point
we can then map that column to shape
encoding
because technically every spike can be
thought of as a unique shape
but when we do that we get this
if you look closely it's just circles
and diamonds crosses and rectangles
what happens is that alde sees your
string column as a category
and starts scaling it to a specific set
of default symbols
but we can say that do not use the
default symbols or the scale
i want you to scale the data using this
particular column while drawing the
points
we do that by setting scale to none in
the shape encoding
for the new column and voila
we can just as easily make an
interactive plot to see how the virus
hotspots
progress over time